教育に失敗して引っこもりだけで何十万、
何百万とできちまった。彼らはもう一生
ダメなんだよ。誰が責任取るんやな。一生
ダメなのに誰も責任者がおらんやろ。で、
生活保護者にしてやる。ちゃんと
生き取れる。だからええやろって言っとる
んや。とんでもない話や。ライトオブ
ライフな。生命権と訳しとる。誰でも
生きる権利があるんだと。だから生活保護
を与えればそれでええんだ。これが奴らの
解釈よ。だけどライトオブライフはね、
生命権生きてるだけじゃなしに生活権と
訳した方がええぞ。ちゃんとした生活を
送る権利な。引っこもりなんかちゃんとし
たあれのわけないじゃん。結婚ができない
ちゃんとした生活やないじゃん。子供を
作らない。ちゃんとした生活やないよ。老
の生活が心配ちゃんとした生活やないよ。
そこだと考えにゃ。だから生き取るだけで
はダめ。ちゃんと行動し、正しい行動し
続ける。これが大事なんや。あれはね、
逃げだよ。だから文化系はダメなんなあ。
自分たちの言い訳ばっかり作っとる。もう
一刻も早く教育。保守が教育する。ヤ和魂
でやる。ちゃんとした人間が出来上がり、
ちゃんとした一生を送る。これが大事な。
早くともかく一刻も早く今のあの何百万と
いう引っこもりをなんとかし責任を取ら
せよう。あいつらが働かんから働けないん
やけど。GDP下がるわけやろ。日本が
ダメになってくわけ。あれらがちゃんと
働かないから国際競争力を低下するわけ
やろからGDPまだ韓国より上だと言っ
たって1人当たりのGDPは韓国の方が上
なんやで。その何百万の人間が足を
引っ張っとるんにや。その何百万の人間を
作り出したのは文部省マスコミないや
。
国連が日本の天皇の女系天皇について人権侵害みたいな国連の会議で指摘してきたみたいなニュースがあって
な。あれは日本が言うんだ。日本の除権主義者が国連に対してそういうあれを出せということ言うわけよ。からね。そのよそのその国の文化に口を出すなって言ったね。
あれは日本はずっとこの何千年男系天皇の
元に統一してきた国なんや。女系天皇の何
がいかん?男系天皇をずっと維持してきた
ということは男のDNAそいつを守ってき
たということなんだ。女系天皇にはそれが
なくなるから女性天皇はええけど女系天皇
はいかんのやな。あれ女性天皇がいかんと
はちっとも言ってないやろ。女系天皇が
いかんって言っとるんや。あ、マスコミの
バカは理解できんわね。そういうことが昔
からそれは中国でもあの真の思考が
紛論語とかああいうものをみんな燃やし
ちまって授教の学者は行きめにしちまった
と授教を抹殺しようとしたんやね。
あれが消しからんことだ。言って言っとるのに戦後アメリカはそれをやったやないか。大和魂禁止で実際に書そういう本を全部燃やしちしちまったんやで。そんとして文句言わんのかね。
[音楽]
燃やしちゃったんですか?
そうだよ。だからこんな2
冊のこんな熱い本があるわ。GHQ
に没収された本。GHQ
の没集を免そういう一覧表があるんや。こんな熱い本になっとるんやで。
全部没収しちまった。都合の悪いのは。
結局アメリカは公平に見て日本がこんなに
発展しさらに強くなったわけやろ。こいつ
はヤ和魂があったからだということになっ
た。それが結論や。だから今後とも大和魂
を残したらまたいつかアメリカはやられる
ということね。だから大和魂をなくし
ちまえ。その代わりリベラルを与えときゃ
国は弱くなる。だからリベラルに帰っ
ちまえよの文化がひっくり返したんやね。
[音楽]